In one cross-test, the Foundation thought
SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy Reptile, would
bite off more than it could chew with SCP-807,
a deadly plate from the Last Chance Diner.
This plate makes any food placed on it
extra delicious, but also makes them extra
unhealthy - so unhealthy that people who eat
its food tend to die of massive heart attacks.
They used the plate to transmute two
SCP-682 Specials - a mix of 10 kg of
rotten meat and sharpened bone splinters, 10
L of rancid mayonnaise, 1 L potassium cyanide,
and 1 kg morphine hydrochloride -
considered a 5-star course for our pal
SCP-682 - and fed it to the beast.
At first, it seemed immobile. Perhaps the
monster had been bested? But when D-Classes
entered to check, the creature’s
skin ruptured in several areas,
ejecting high-pressure jets of
its own blood in every direction,
killing them all. The reptile was completely fine
afterward and eagerly ate a third 682 Special.